der bus hat einen diplomatenkennzeichen
und steht auf dem parkplatz von
russlands vertretung in berlin es ist
donnerstagabend die botschaft packt die
kisten und koffer sind das reisegepäck
der 40 diplomaten die deutschland
rausschmeißt weil sie irritiert agitiert
und spioniert haben sollen die seit
montag unerwünschten personen wollen
nicht erkannt und sollen nicht gefilmt
werden eine solche
massenausweisung gab es noch nie das ist
das ist schon ein schlag ins kontor muss
man sagen wir haben auch in meiner zeit
als ich an moskau war ausweisung erlebt
das waren in der regel einzelfälle ist
eine größenordnung die ich jedenfalls
bisher noch nicht erlebt hat es geht um
grössenordnungen in diesen tagen die
noch niemand erlebt hat borodjanka
butscher gräueltaten die alles verändern
die vorstellbar kite die sprache die
diplomatie wird jemals wieder ein
vertreter der bundesregierung mit putin
an einem tisch sitzen können und sei es
ein noch so großer die tötung von
zivilisten sind kriegsverbrechen und die
verantwortung für diese verbrechen trägt
der russische präsident putin vor
gericht das ist jetzt auch der wunsch
des kanzleramts aber nicht seine
erwartung und noch nicht seine politik
carla del ponte war chef anklägerin des
internationalen
strafgerichtshofs sie fordert konkrete
schritte einen anfang ich bin die
einzige sehr wahrscheinlich die beweisen
kann dass man ein präsident einer nation
von gericht bringen kann wir haben
nichts gemacht mit milosevic war musste
auch serbiens präsident milosevic erst
gestürzt werden bis er 2001 in
handschellen nach den haag kommt aber
die anklage steht sie hat gewartet sie
hat erfolg
auch bei milosevic hatten politiker
darunter deutsche lange auf dialog
gesetzt wie bei putin und doch anders
zumindest von mir nicht zu überzeugen
aber der versuch den fand nicht richtig
aber weil putin ist das doch jetzt eine
ganz andere situation wir haben jetzt
wirklich kriegsverbrechen ich meine
mutter und so weiter muss man sich ja
nur ansehen so dass man solche gespräche
mit ihm gar nicht mehr zu führen braucht
es handelt sich hier um ein land welches
atomwaffen besitzt und die höchste kunst
der diplomatie ist auch mit solch
schwierigen gesprächspartner weiter im
gespräch zu bleiben kann man im gespräch
bleiben mit einem kriegsverbrecher
kanzler scholz hat sich entschieden auch
in zukunft mit putin zu telefonieren um
die botschaften der ukraine zu
verbreiten und zu verstärken und im
übrigen auch die gelegenheit zu nutzen
den russischen präsidenten zu sagen wie
die lage wirklich ist also zum beispiel
über das ausmaß der
getöteten russischen soldaten alles
dinge die er vielleicht nicht aus seinem
engsten umfeld so fahren wird wenn nicht
andere es ihnen auch noch mal sagen
jedes wort mit putin oder lavrov
legitimiert das regime festigt seine
macht und normalisiert seine verbrechen
so die kritik vor allem aus osteuropa am
deutschen dauer gespräch mit dem kreml
das bringt es nicht wir haben viele
telefonate gesehen aber keine effekte
wenn du mir wenn mir jemand
wenigstens ein effekt zeigen wird werde
ich von dieser kritik abschaffen putin
zu zeigen dass es auch für ihn einen
ausweg gibt ein danach war ein ziel der
bundesregierung vor
bis vor kurzem war das eine position die
ich auch vertreten hätte
aber ich kann mir
einen normalen umgang mit ihnen
jedenfalls aus unserer sicht und aus der
sicht der der restlichen westlichen welt
unter den jetzigen umständen kaum
vorstellen als die 40 ausgewiesenen
diplomaten die botschaft verlassen
versuchen russische schultern
fernsehaufnahmen zu verhindern es wird
sehr lange dauern bis der erste
zurückkehrt und das erste zeichen von
normalität